[Musique]
info ou intox c'est avec vous anthony st
léger bonjourbonjour natasa bonjour à
tous et d'abord retour sur ce convoi de
la liberté au canada ces files de
camions qui ces derniers jours ont
rejoint ottawa la capitale ils
protestent contre l'obligation vaccinale
qui leur est faite pour franchir la
frontière entre le canada et les états
unis le mouvement aurait fait des émules
à l'étranger selon plusieurs internautes
oui à en croire des affirmations faites
à partir de vidéos devenue virale on va
en voir trois exemples ce soir la
première c'est celle ci regardait les
partager essentiellement sur twitter fin
janvier on voit donc cette file de
camions est l'une des légendes et bien
c'est cette c'est celle ci que les
camionneurs italien se mobilise
maintenant avec les camionneurs
australien alors pourquoi australien
parce que ça fait référence à une
manifestation deux camionneurs
australiens qui ont des revendications
similaires à leurs confrères canadiens
et la légende aussi de préciser unissons
nos forces avec tous ensemble donc avec
le canada le deuxième exemple la seconde
vidéo c'est celle ci on la trouve à la
fois sur twitter et sur youtube depuis
quelques jours maintenant elle montre
une dizaine de camions avec vous le
voyez des drapeaux brésiliens la légende
là encore le brésil solidaire du canada
c'est écrit en haut et puis le troisième
exemple on est sept fois sur tik tok un
autre convoi de camions plus de 157
mille vue et le titre qu'on veuille in
s6 s6 pour caroline du sud états du sud
des états unis il n'y a pas d'autres
légendes mais il ya un des commentaires
qui peut attirer l'attention c'est celui
ci qui nous dit les camionneurs canadien
aussi sont avec vous vous remercie plus
précisément vous soutiennent également
cette internaute croyant comprendre donc
il ya bien un soutien des camionneurs de
caroline du sud à leurs confrères
canadiens et qu'en est il réellement
anthony ces vidéos montre-t-elle des
soutiens internationaux convoi de la
liberté canadien alors non ça ne veut
pas dire qu'il n'y en a pas ou qu'il n'y
en aura pas puisqu'il ya d'ailleurs des
appels pour converger vers paris ou
bruxelles mais ce n'est pas ce que
montrent ces 3
vidéo la première on y revient c'est
donc cette vidéo de file de camions que
l'on voit on est bien en italie et on
peut lire ici au regard des as autorise
pas radio ni pardon pour l'accent bord
s'est hissée quoi c'est un atelier de
réparation de voiture et il n'y en a
qu'un qui porte ce nom on le voit ici
vous voyez grâce à google maps on est
dans la ville de carmagnole près de
turin et cette vidéo en fête a été
tournée le 25 septembre dernier ce
défilé de camions c'est un petit peu une
tradition s'est organisée chaque année à
cette période pour la fête de saint
michel qui célèbre l'archange saint
michel et la rédaction des observateurs
de france 24 d'ailleurs à contacter ses
confrères de fact checking italien et il
n'y a pour l'heure aucune connaissance
de soutien italien contre les
camionneurs italiens contre les
restrictions sanitaires et pour ce qui
est des camions avec les drapeaux
brésiliens alors on la revoit ici et
vous voyez qu'elle était déjà sur
twitter le 15 mai 2021 il s'agit là en
fait d'une manifestation en soutien à
jaillir à bolton arrow le président au
brésilien ou peu à dire vraiment pour
les restrictions sanitaires et
l'obligation vaccinale on la retrouve
facilement sur twitter cette vidéo grâce
aux mots clés en portugais convoi et
camionneurs l'équipe là encore de france
24 au brésil a confirmé qu'il n'y avait
pas pour l'heure de rassemblement de
camionneurs en soutien au convoi de la
liberté canadien et puis on va voir
cette troisième vidéo celle de tik tok
dont je vous parlais elle a été partagée
par michele bottomley que l'on voit ici
c'est le nom qui apparaît il dirige
l'entreprise éponyme une société trop de
transport routier de caroline du nord et
le convoi est celui qui a été organisée
le 28 août dernier en direction de la
caroline du sud le but c'était de
collecter des fonds pour une
organisation caritative de caroline du
sud qui vise à aider les personnes ayant
une déficience intellectuelle et ce
convoi de la liberté généré de
nombreuses réactions même le dessin
animé les simpson on en parle a
effectivement on va découvrir ensemble
cette vidéo qui circule sur les réseaux
sociaux qui a surpris de nombreux
internautes tentent elles et elles
collent à la réalité de par sa
clairvoyance
regardez on y voit homer simpson au
volant d'un camion avec son his heart
suivi par un convoi de plusieurs camions
et dans la foulée vous voyez un homme
politique qui ressemble quand même à
juste entre nous on voit d'ailleurs les
drapeaux derrière le premier ministre
canadien qui sortent par la fenêtre de
son bureau alors vrai ou faux et bien
c'est un peu des deux parce que cette
prédiction de la série animée c'est ce
qu'on peut lire ici et là sur les
réseaux sociaux regardez cet internaute
qui nous dit un épisode de 99 me trudeau
s'enfuir après l'arrivée d'un convoi de
camions sauf que c'était un petit peu
trop gros pour être vrai ces deux
extraits sont authentiques mais ils ont
bien été diffusée dans les simpson c'est
vrai mais ils ont vingt ans d'écart le
premier lot de 99 au maire échappe à des
routiers à qui tente de le qui essaye de
lui bloquer le passage et le deuxième
est bien on est en 2000 2009 2019 pardon
si j'ai bien calculer et on voit
effectivement justin trudeau en train de
faire des petites cabriole il répond en
fait à lisa par skype est pourquoi il
s'en va tout simplement parce qu'elle
évoque les accusations de corruption
liée aux à la société snc lavalin et
c'est pour ça qu'il prend la poudre
d'escampette donc l'assemblage des deux
séquences n'a absolument à elle n'a
absolument rien à voir l'une avec
l'autre mais évidemment on joue sur
l'actualité là encore et puis on joue
sur ses prédictions à répétition que
l'on a attribué au dessin animé les
simpson la plupart du temps d'ailleurs à
tort puisque ce sont souvent des
photomontages ou des images non officiel
de la série qui sont reprises hors
contexte vous invite d'abord d'ailleurs
avoir plusieurs pages de la rédaction d
observateur consacré à la question les
observateurs sur france 24 points comme
merci beaucoup anthony st léger pour
votre chronique